show what kind of player that uh daniel
dubois is he's creative he's dynamic
he's attacking he's he's your definition
of never go back
to attack and okay duboiv is finally
ready for the game to start and he
pushes his king's pawn as well
magnus carson will we see him go to the
opening he used against annie giri a
couple of rounds ago no he goes for the
spanish opening the white bishop coming
out putting pressure on the black knight
indirectly therefore putting pressure on
black center spanish opening how will
duboff react the berlin defense i mean
i thought we'd never see duboff play the
berlin in his life
magnus just defending that and doobot
developing his bishop so
do both you're choosing one of the most
solid openings
out there for black we did see a trade
bishop for night and now the game will
take a maybe a slower pace
but definitely has been played
throughout the ages yep i mean
it's a very very popular plan this exact
scenario but the idea
is known so if white does bring the
knight forward the white knight will
be stopped from jumping further magnus
we mentioned it he loves to push pawns
on that left side which side is with the
black king gonna go
dubov pushes a pawn now he's hinting
that he's gonna go
towards that right side the black king
no
longer will be safe now that black has
started pushing pawns on the other side
of the board
but duboff is forced to trade so magnus
he's very much playing the opponent
in times like these you just want to you
know what you're putting at once you
know that their style is very attacking
so you just want to simplify
you want to get rid of their attacking
ammunition and
okay black finally does commit the king
he will castle
yeah he's taking some time out okay
develop his knight
but moving his knight is that sort of an
indication that
maybe it's going to go the other way
around towards the center so this is why
duboff
played his bishop to that square so the
knight is not allowed to go to that
square but there's still
you know the possibility of transferring
the knight to
the right side of the ward i'm guessing
but okay i was going to say
it feels like the right moment to castle
but no he's going after his opponent's
bishop
that's going to come back to haunt
duboff later yeah so
okay the bishop steps away from a
potential trade will morphy
or rather a game that was never played
okay yeah all right what's happening
the white knight jump forward attacking
the black queen the black queen just
stepping back so there's some pressure
on black's central pawn right now
let's go into the board and uh let's
check out there is actually as you
mentioned there is a trap
firstly black will step forward this
attacking this knight kicking it back
it's only got one safe square the knight
goes back and now as you mentioned
ivanka this knight jumps forward and
white's queen has no more escape squares
it needs to stay on this diagonal
protecting its own knight but it cannot
do that any longer and once the queen
moves away from the attack of black's
knight
then the other white knight will be
captured so an
indirect attack there on the white
knight
this white knight dropping off on this
square that is why magnus carlsen
he saw this he saw that the knight is
vulnerable here so he's retreated it
and i like this a lot there's a lot of
pressure now on black central pawn and
black's been forced to attack the white
queen
as the white queen stepped back and now
the black knight is kind of
superficially
defending this pawn because it's about
to get kicked back white will kick back
this black knight
and uh what happens if black goes okay
fine i'm just going to push my pawn
forward
this one okay well actually yeah okay
well we actually have a move on the
board he's
he's pushed his pawn forward so the king
definitely feels safer
over on that right side but we'll see
okay he does
kick than black knight and now duboff
he's had time he doesn't retreat the
night where he would have lost a pawn
okay we've seen those knights disappear
from the board white capturing the black
knight black capturing
the other knight and now tripled pawns
for black off
you look at the sea line tripled pawns
that's never ideal
maybe we'll see a trade at some point
but who will this favor the bishop or
the knight
we have an answer david he's moved his
rook wow to defend it now that was not a
move i suspected i
i don't know why i had this idea in my
head that he might use the other rook to
defend the pawn
he wants to use the rook bringing up the
rook exactly
and hit that central pawn like that and
now we're expecting duboff to play
bishop take spawn as he does and
magnus getting greedy this is i'm not so
sure about this last move but this is
both players in a nutshell
is there like obvious moves for him now
or
well there we have it um yeah it's
obvious for him
maybe not for not for us not for some
but he does
bring us rook to an open line attacking
a pawn again it feels like that's the
kind of move that he could have saved
for later maybe
instincts are normally materialistic um
but magnus he does defend it so yeah
you're right it's probably it makes a
lot of sense to defend that pawn the
opponent's king a bit vulnerable he
doesn't trade
he goes back with the bishop not to the
square you wanted but attacking the
white queen
kicking that white queen back continue
being greedy
magnus takes it javanka no he doesn't
follow your advice
this this one was no touch this one came
with a warning because you know
it wasn't that rook that i was worried
about attacking the queen it was the
other rook
this rook yes but what happens if i get
greedy no no no no no not that work
keep keep my rook defending the pawn the
other rig that's
the rook i was saying that's the one
that's the one okay
and uh now okay dubois played it and now
once the queen moves as
it has done now duboff has the option to
just take this pawn and suddenly black's
rook is super active
it doesn't look like a good trade for
white he's just allowed the opponent's
rook to get
um to get into his position and now
short okay this is the position on the
board
now surely magnus now is the time don't
forget okay he does
castle he does finally find safety for
his king that
that just means with best player with
perfect play both sides by both sides it
would be a draw but
win the game magnus winning a pawn now
um
okay now magnus two pawns up for black
if you take that knight then suddenly
your bishop would be under attack but
the black
retreating white can just move the queen
back um because
only one move saves your knight right
now he does find the best leader in the
best move
absolutely and uh magnus he does make
his move
magnus makes his move for a sensible one
he just brings this rook across
defending a weak pawn so black's bishop
trying to attack some pawns
at the moment everything's protected by
white winning against uh who you found
wesley saw and digging play the draw
svidler was able to win his game against
adiba
you you were quite critical about it we
were like no you can't play like that's
too straightforward
and uh well it's on the board now so
it's on the board the most direct line
but it just makes white's task easier
as we mentioned black's queen has to
move the bishop or the rook will drop
off
most likely you should well you should
keep your rook rather than the bishop
right so
maybe he stays thinking okay i dropped
my queen back
and then after queen takes bishop then i
can play queen
i have to go queen takes porn why not
and oh it's on the board
and now when magnus plays you take spawn
as well queen takes pawn
you go ah here we go
that's that's how we create chaos
it sounded very cocky when you said here
we go here we go oh yeah apples and
pears
okay magnus now trying to kick away that
black queen yeah from the center
makes a lot of sense there was a small
trick in the position um if black had
taken a pawn with his queen but he
didn't fall for that
sudden blitz attack against the white
king but magnus trying to trade the
rooks now so rook's on the board i might
have to lose time okay well
he does it dubob does it he lines up
both his rooks against
white's weak if magnus can just swap off
queens
it's going to be an impossible task for
duboff to save the game
so magnus using his rook to kick away
the black queen also potentially eyeing
up the pawn behind it
so black's queen has to go back to a
square that defends that black pawn
uh out there on the right so nice move
by magnus
black's queen is going to have to go to
a passive okay i was going to say back
to a passive square
instead she steps forward we will we
want to bank it
put it in the bag and just guaranis
finds it
and um the most human move i think just
getting rid of
any potential risk if the queen's come
on at least you know you won't get
chapmated
uh he's been checkmated too many times
by dubois and although the evaluation
bar doesn't fully approve it just keeps
a winning advantage
and it removes all risks so very very
sensible the black queen if it moves
the pawn behind it will be captured has
allowed the exchange of queens
and we now have a double rook ending i
mean yeah
uh it's very little hope now and magnus
that that move i think is the killer
that move is so accurate because the
whole point the only chance that black
had in this position
is if they if if duboff manages to line
up the two rooks
along the second row then there's some
trouble and it doesn't even matter if
you actually lose a pawn
on the right side and you might and you
trade as long as you trade a set of
rooks that's what counts
all right well uh another game has
actually finished are temiev
on the board just hope that magnus kind
of pushes his pawns too quickly
or that he kind of forgets to trade a
set of ruxin and then there might be a
chance and that's the key whichever pawn
advances
you attack the pawn that protects it the
further most back pawn that's going to
be
dubois strategy right now but magnus
keeping everything together
now i'm wondering if it's going to be a
big issue for magnus carlsen 18 seconds
it is okay he plays the move that i was
thinking about
and now i'm expecting to see the black
rook
attack one of the pawns meeting nets
yeah yeah okay so actually
yeah okay magnus is killing killing the
game
so the mating net that i saw was
basically involving uh it was very
ambitious but it was all to do with the
fact that the white king is stuck in the
back rank and maybe
there's the possibility of advancing
your pawns and keeping the king caged in
i and now the bar is getting excited
finally the bar's getting excited maybe
black just had to grit his teeth and
take white porn
white's corner upon that and just hope
for the best and pray that he was
able to save that game and stop white's
remaining porn is the only chance it was
the only chance but this way
it feels like he's just okay but this is
a little bit sneaky right is there more
than one winning move i'm not so sure
anymore
he does take that pawn off maybe it was
better to actually ignore that pawn okay
oh
he made that with one second to spare
wow gosh keeping us on the edge of our
seats
so uh okay now if i were magnus i would
just simply hold on to that pawn
activities active instead okay still a
nice idea
yep a nice idea there one second
did he make a move yes he did two
seconds to spare
but now magnus is about to gobble up a
second pawn and
two pawn advantage yes he's lost what
his far advanced past pawn but
he's gonna get an extra pawn on both
sides of the board this should be
winning for magnus
okay now he swaps off a set of rooks and
that is game over
we mentioned as soon as one set of rooks
come off the board black has no more
counter play
no more attack against the white king
and all magnus needs to do
trade that set of rooks protect your
pawn in the corner there and
slowly but surely you'll create two past
pawns and those will overwhelm black's
army
right exactly and the pawn that's there
on the left is kind of more or less the
decoy that's gonna
hold just tie the black rock down and
uh there's just really nothing to be
done here and
magnus pushing his pawn forward
there's nothing you know what to do rick
takes rook king takes
and now black if anything black can do
is just wait yeah and
there is a saying that all rook end
games are drawn it's kind of
tongue-in-cheek
but not all rookie games are a draw not
when you're two pawns up
uh when they're two healthy pawns as
they are here and there we go magnus
just taking kind of baby steps just
stepping one square forward with his
pawn next he'll centralize the white
king
and yeah that shows uh shows optimism
but yeah magnus he's again the end game
king he's not going to let this one slip
and okay yeah it looks like dubo is
about to give up
yeah he knows that it's inevitable he
can slow things down but
the result is not going to change
white's slowly going to step forward
with his pawn there we go
black's rook will be tied down stopping
that pawn and then white will make a
passport on the other side
dubo thinking is there anything he can
do to trick magnus
i guess that's not it nope unfortunately
not he's trying to trade a set of pawns
he's hoping
for some stalemates he's gonna try and
trap his own black king and hope that uh
hope that magnus walks into some uh
tricky stalemate there that was
that was very uh very cunning but magnus
he actually brought his rook up
releasing squares for the black king
right exactly and uh it's like that
whole of a
whole note song like i can't go for that
no can do
so yeah very nice and uh we have a
result
magnus carlsen wins against dan o'dubov
yep